welcome to grunts castle bite flame this
is the three and I need to turn on
generator and I need to do it fast I
think I didn't read but anyway as it's
made by Fellini 3ni you should know him
by now I mean I made a lotta played a
lot of hitch custom story they're always
fun and definitely unique what the heck
is this this is what the closet oh man
already I have to that dinner I feel so
much better with this in my house I
don't even care I don't even care like
all the guys hop painting I'm sure
printed I downloaded magic get out of my
way okay good to know what is it dear
huh
if someone is emo face alright yeah this
why why is there something here this is
my emo phase
I don't know if that was any difference
in my regular haha painting Thomas here
all right this is yeah oh well scare the
crap out of me even though I don't have
any all right we're gonna go here down
nice and easy
ah that was a good one Oh bro oh boy oh
boy oh my god now I get that oh I get it
how could this happen to me how did they
do to you I can lift these oh they're so
cute oh no
Finnick hey I love you please reconsider
this decision I'll do anything for you
bet don't don't throw me in I swear oh
I'll massage your feet every night and
I'll kiss your butt and shave your butt
for you alright I'll do it
I'm trying mr. now oh man the thing is
that here we have to go oh god they're
so [ __ ] many alright let's just let's
just go nothing how about hater hater
how you doing girl boy on approvers I
knew it why didn't you tell me I was
missing chair mode actually I've tried
to tell you that's right
Oh God corridors you're coming with me
oh man do I have to be I mean I like you
know that you're not what's going on oh
god it's getting doc pity really I'm
afraid of darkness please don't do this
to me
hey Sam Oh I'm gonna go in ceremony you
know as soon as you drop me I'm gonna
[ __ ] go to share mode now I don't
care anymore Jeremy
what the [ __ ] was that what why did you
do it
whatever I'm better I'm down here I
think I misheard Joker's it sound like a
fine Oh barrels
I don't just you know I trust you I
trust you I trust you oh it was your lip
get out of my way bounce there brap brap
come out of here [ __ ] out of here all
right we're good
actually I don't think we're good hey
wait up wait which way which way
oh no Bros everywhere Bros positive Oh
God black pretty sweet all right don't
try to block the seekers for me mr.
Sherr I know what you're planning I
don't use it I know your [ __ ] and I know
shares don't [ __ ] so that's good enough
for me let's toast for a pity aisle all
right Wow potatoes in the closet why are
you hiding here for mr. potato Hey
potatoes hiding from the bro in the
convent right so I guess I'm gonna go
here come on girl my girl why never mind
got a bot girl boy girl boy ah
so many things to lose should I really
do this I doubt there's anything to be
honest for always also super important
secret
oh don't worry [ __ ] guys I hate that
affording naked oh [ __ ]
look bro I my I think I broke my I can't
say anything why did it go dark Oh God
oh the cable the cable fell out from the
screen wait let me see if I can fix it
all right sorry about that I don't know
if you can see me
are you better all right is it bad that
Jesus Christ I got me good I got me
really good sorry I don't know what that
was
got them didn't even stay I could have
tea that Himmler something but knew I'm
a teleporting naked guy you knew about
this didn't you mr. chair he was
[ __ ] on me and I get off me I only
want Petey's but anyway let's go to the
sewer sewer of doom yeah that sounds
great
can't wait was super of doom
all right we're start here sewer let's
go down to just wow I like this this
sign it's pretty cool oh no the water
monster oh god there's not a lot of maps
that use the water monster I don't why I
mean look does that mean alright I'm
gonna jump these anyway cuz I don't
trust anything oh no you're not getting
any hugs you know what you get Danah
scare me I didn't scream but that's good
you know what you get you get box I'd
hug that box you wanna heart I give you
heart all day all night long damn
[ __ ] teleporting thank you guys
teleporting [ __ ] guys those are the
worse why didn't mr. chair doing mr.
shell what are you doing it's not a
freaking spot this is not a spy mr.
chair wow it's pretty cool ma'am
waterfalls in [ __ ] I don't appreciate
hugs
I didn't say gay play sad face I didn't
say gate play yeah really
I didn't say Gabe
all right this is go go I don't good
corridors where's Stefano
oh come on out I need you I don't trust
this at all no so bad I got a new place
what do you want what do you want those
series Oh what do you want why do you
want from me stupid shower more accurate
all right really
Wow I really love all of these customers
people that make it for me it's really
all right Wow what's going on here oh
[Applause]
god that was a lot of I don't know if
that's poor period then that's not that
was C buzzer voice again wow that little
troll he never told me about this I have
no idea
all right let's take this Kia I picked
up hey what's right
it's purchase soon you scare me too
strong for this p.m. on come on it stop
hauling I know you're in there alright
let's go yeah I like that a lot you know
alright I've it I mean gangbang get that
that's my voice what the heck
hey what's up this ow hey
oh hello feeding we're just sharing here
alone Lena pom I'm so freakin poem but
damn we were just sitting here ah man
rubbing each other naked buddies against
each other in the cozy fire if a cozy
fireplace you like you know you like
when I burn my penis on the candle you
like that you like when I'm penis on
fire you like that you're like big your
penis PD you like that you like when I
eat fire beauty you like that you're
like you like when I do that I know I
know you like it I know you like do you
like that you like this you know when I
sneak up behind and be like hey pity
how you doing you want to you know I
could be on this side and you can be on
the other side and we could just stuff
to get it you like that are you into
that kind of sup you is that cool with
you
I mean I'm a pig a lot of people think
I'm a snake but no I'm a pig I think you
like that you like the fact that
no I don't like that all right fine pick
it move now if we awesome if someone
could like mod Piggy so I can bring it
with me it's too heavy you see I can't
pick it come on
I'm pump I've shopped frigging pump I
wish I could go with you I wish I wish
all right we can go a little bit cuz
then people would get pissed and be like
oh I don't even know anymore
piggy please move I mean perfect bigoted
what are you doing get out of here oh
god I'm on boy high whatever
who needs oil anyway right piggy I don't
know I mean it's dark now you know what
that means you know when it gets dark
people oh look there's a bed ready for
us I'm just gonna lay here and get naked
and if you want to come with me that's
totally cool at all I mean I'm a snake
all right Oh Oh God bro oh oh oh god I
don't trust this at all
I'm gonna go insane for shizzle and my
snitch halt all right mr. sheriff I need
help I need to seriously help Oh God
oh we can go
yeah I'm gonna end here bros hope you
enjoyed sorry about a shorter video I
had a lot of trouble recording today so
that's just how it is sometimes
anyway like and favorite and all that
counter stuff subscribe and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
oh that's where the lighter comes in oh
god I don't like this Oh